web graphics library is a javascript api
for implementing
interactive 2d and 3d vector graphics in
the browser
it allows developers to run hardware
accelerated graphics with the client's
gpu
directly inside an html canvas without
the need for external plugins it opens
the door to 3d web design
interactive games data vis physics
simulations and most importantly
beautiful artwork
webgl is used to render graphics in
everyday tools like google maps and by
the unity engine to make web-based games
to understand how it works it helps to
first understand basic 3d theory
and the rendering pipeline in a 3d scene
every point is a vertex
identified by its x y and z coordinates
the vertices are then connected together
to form a bunch of little triangles
known as primitives
then a light source bounces off of them
to create the appearance of shadows and
depth perception they're then rasterized
to convert
a 3d vector graphic into a projection of
a 2d pixel
which tricks our brains into seeing a 3d
object on a 2-dimensional computer
screen
this pipeline can be customized by
writing shaders which are just functions
that tell the computer how to draw
pixels on the screen
shading requires the computer to perform
a ton of linear algebra or matrix
multiplication
to render graphics smoothly at 60fps
it's often too much for the cpu to
handle by itself which is why we have
gpus to distribute the calculations more
efficiently webgl
allows us to process graphics on the gpu
and is based on a library that's been
around since 1992 called opengl
to get started you just need to grab an
html canvas in the dom
then get its webgl contacts to start
drawing the main program code is written
in javascript
but shaders are written in the opengl es
shading language
a shader will take information about a
vertex or fragment and use the gpu to
calculate the data required to render it
as a pixel on the screen
luckily you don't need to write shaders
by hand to start adding 3d graphics to
your website you can use libraries like
3js or tools like spline to quickly
design 3d experiences without much
underlying knowledge of webgl
stay tuned for a full 3js tutorial make
sure to hit the like button
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one